ich male der film von einem sehr
berühmten regisseur nämlich jim jarmusch
den kennen glaube ich noch so ziemlich
alle leute die sich überhaupt in den
letzten 30 jahren für kino intensiver
interessiert haben sozusagen der
gottvater des amerikanischen independent
kinos
es geht darum dass ein nun sagen wir
herr namens peterson in einer ortschaft
namens peterson täglich in einer
buslinie fährt die als endbahnhof
petersen hat das heißt wir haben eine
dreifache art von rechtfertigung des
titels des films der eben auch petersen
heißt da haben wir mit einem busfahrer
zu tun denn nun überhaupt nichts
heldenhaftes tut sondern der dichtet und
der aber in gewisser weise über sein
eigenes dichten nicht nur sich selbst
eine gewisse rechtfertigung über den
beruf hinaus verschafft sondern auch die
ganze gesellschaft betrachtet und damit
ein ganz harmonisches verhältnis zu
dieser gesellschaft entwickelt heißt er
wirklich pattinson oder ist dessen
spitzname nein mein name ist wirklich
körpers und zu hause wartet eine ganz
reizende frau mit einem fantastischen
ästhetischen empfinden und die bestärkt
ihn darin er möge doch endlich mal seine
dichtung publizieren aber er will das
eigentlich gar nicht das klingt jetzt
als könnte es eine art drama werden ich
habe das aber überhaupt nicht so das
wird eine ganz zauberhafte mit einem
komische komödie jedes gedicht wenn es
für dich ist wird es das wohl sein
es wurde inspiriert von unseren ohio
blutig streichhölzern wirklich jeder der
nicht unbedingt nur action filme sehen
will sondern auch ein hang zur komödie
hat und da nicht unbedingt jetzt auf
unglaublich viel fäkalhumor und ähnliche
dinge setzt der ist in diesem film von
jim jarmusch absolut richtig das dürfte
der film von james sein der das größte
publikum erfreuen würde morgen nein
eigentlich nicht
das willst du gar nicht wissen